hablando del aborto hablando de la salud
ya nos acompaña en nuestro estudio más
romeros al amar muy buen día feliz
martes es para ti empezamos en francia
porque la empresa sanofi anunció que
abandona sus esfuerzos para desarrollar
una vacuna contra el coi 19 marc que más
hay sobre esto así es de hecho los
motivos que adujeron son más
empresariales que científicos porque de
hecho los resultados del estudio que
estaban haciendo que estaba llegando a
fase 2 con por una vacuna contra el
hobbit 19 habían sido positivos pero
calculan que esto se aprobaría a finales
de 2022 siendo optimistas y que en ese
momento no tendría sentido seguir
desarrollando una vacuna y ponerla en el
mercado recordemos que la tecnología que
usan es una tecnología de arn mensajero
eso lo que hace es enseñar a las células
a protegerse contra el commit 19 sin
necesidad de inocular un virus inactivo
de la enfermedad precisamente esta
tecnología que se ha desarrollado
gracias a la investigación contra el 19
es muy valiosa y sanofi la va a
aprovechar para desarrollar una nueva
vacuna contra la gripe así es marc
cambiamos de información pero seguimos
hablando de un de los competidores de
sanofi hablamos de facer porque tienen
noticias también sobre su carrera
farmacéutica para desarrollar
medicamentos contra el quabit 19 así es
de sin confundir la crónica de salud con
la economía de nuestra compañera daniela
blando no y estamos pisando nos un poco
los talones porque fai se inició un
estudio con más de 2.600 pacientes así
fue como lo anunciaron
el sexo es si hay éxito esta terapia
antiviral oral contra el hobbit 19
podría complementar esfuerzos de
prevención más amplios además de las
vacunas como tratamiento potencial para
gente que contraiga o se haya expuesto
al virus pues todo género es claro raúl
tendría unas ventajas increíbles tener
una pastilla contra él como 19 para
personas que estén infectadas sería
mucho más fácil de administrar que una
vacuna por ejemplo y lo que hace este
medicamento bueno lo que vamos a ver si
lo hace de manera efectiva de hecho es
bloquear una enzima que permite la
reproducción del virus eso significa que
una persona se puede contagiar o puede
estar en contacto con el virus sin
reproducirlo luego y esparcirlo en su
cuerpo y a otras personas esto además
supone un vacío gigante en el mercado
apenas hay tratamientos para personas
contagiadas de kobe de 19 y pues facer
busca también cosechar estas estas
investigaciones súper buena noticia mar
seguimos hablando en la pandemia kobe 19
y como afectado la crisis sanitaria la
esperanza de nuestra vida mar en pocas
palabras mal se trata de la mayor caída
en la esperanza de vida en europa al
menos desde la la guerra mundial es un
estudio de la universidad de oxford que
recogió datos de 29 países y concluyó
que en 27 se redujo la esperanza de vida
aquí tienen algunos ejemplos en verde
están las mujeres en azul están en los
hombres y vemos que por ejemplo el mayor
desplome se da en eeuu donde los hombres
perdieron hasta 2,2 años de esperanza de
vida recordemos que cuesta entre 5 y 6
años por ejemplo en la historia aumentar
en un año la previsión de esperanza de
vida con lo que esto se trata de un
retroceso enorme enorme marque mala
noticia además está impresionante como
dejará eso y después de la segunda
guerra mundial pues también una noticia
que no es muy alentadora terminamos
sanchina a marc donde las autoridades
ayer iniciaron anunciaron que quieren
reducir los abortos por motivos no
médicos qué significa esto además hoy en
el día internacional para un aborto
seguro exacto es muy importante que
tratemos de este tema hoy porque todo
esto es poco claro en china por ejemplo
el aborto es legal pero también estamos
hablando de que sea accesible y de que
sea seguro las autoridades chinas por un
lado están diciendo que van a ampliar
las campañas en educación sexual y el
acceso métodos anticonceptivos esa es
una muy buena noticia sin embargo hay
voces que ahí se están preocupando
porque puede convertirse en una
estigmatización para las mujeres que
quieran interrumpir voluntariamente su
embarazo además no es la primera vez que
china ya habla en estas líneas en 2018
por ejemplo hubo controversia porque
dijeron que el aborto provocaba
infertilidad nosotros vamos a contrastar
esta información con información de la
clínica mayo lo explican muy bien una de
las más prestigiosas de eeuu y esto es
lo que explican
en general se considera que el aborto
lectivo no causa problemas de fertilidad
o complicaciones en embarazos futuros al
parecer un aborto selectivo con
medicamentos no aumenta el riesgo de
complicaciones en embarazos futuros
siempre y cuando se realice bajo la guía
de su equipo de atención médica las
mujeres que se someten a múltiples
abortos quirúrgicos con una curita
corren el riesgo de dejar cicatrices en
el revestimiento interno del útero claro
eso significa que hay un riesgo pero el
riesgo es leve y existe sobre todo si el
aborto se practica muchas veces es un
aborto quirúrgico con lo que en verdad
no hay tantos motivos de preocupación y
no debería convertirse en un motivo para
evitar o estigmatizar la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo así es marc
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información